By ran the six hour parasite program on February 2nd, the next day, I could barely move.
I understand this was a herc cyber reaction, but I'm still struggling to function today.
Every 12th moving, getting dressed, very weak, paid in left arm, from a mastectomy, worse, etc.
So this person, the person who submitted this, we haven't heard from for a long, long time.
So I don't know what else is going on in this person's life, so I would like for this person to
send up a time to talk to me. But I put the question in here anyhow, because I thought it would
be helpful for everybody. So running a parasite program can a person develop a herc cyber
reaction? Remember what the definition of a herc cyber reaction is? Herc cyber reaction was
described by a doctor herc cyber. I don't know what a year ago, I don't know the history of that,
but it's described as when you do something a therapy, whether it's the right machine or it's
supplement or it's a medication, and you end up producing a lot of endotoxins. So an endotoxin
is something that we, a word that we use to describe a toxin that is coming from the inside
of you. So endomines inside. So typically it'd be described as let's say you're killing a single
cell organism. So if you're killing a single cell organism like a bacteria, you're killing it by
the cell going through a cell lysis. So the cell is being broken down. And it's not your cell.
So it's going to produce waste. So that's how it's basically imploding and it's like blowing up. And
now where's that stuff going? Where's all that waste going? Well, it's going to go back into your
lymph system, into your beetle system, into your veins, and it has to go in try to get out through your
liver and your kidneys. And if it overwhelms your liver detoxification pathways, it's going to
circulate in your body and it's going to be deposited elsewhere and it's going to just make you feel
like flu-ish and make you feel icky. Now, if you feel that way from running one parasite program or if
you did a medication, let's say, to kill parasites, or if you did a supplement parasite supplement
program to kill parasites, and you feel that way 10 days later, I don't think it's a hurt-side
reaction because it's not going to be circulated in your body for 10 days. It's just, well, it'll be
pushed into extracellular spaces. It can't stay in your blood that long. It can't. So I don't think
this is a hurt-side reaction. I don't think you're properly diagnosing what's going on. Well,
that happened right after the parasite program. That's what it happened. Maybe. I don't know.
I still don't think it's a hurt-side reaction. You could have some infection. You could have
something else going on. It was coincidental. But this is a word of caution to everybody. If you feel like
you have, you know, Lyme disease, so the worst thing that you're going to get a hurt-side reaction
from is going to be a gram-negative bacteria. Now, there's different bacteria that are
gram-positive, and there's different bacteria that are gram-negative. The most common
gram-negative bacteria that's going to cause a hurt-side reaction is going to be birellia burgodolfi.
Remember what that is? That's Lyme disease. Well, it's part of Lyme disease. And my book Lyme disease
is birellia burgodolfi in then a bunch of other cold infections because almost nobody is only infected
with that bacteria. They're infected with that and other bacteria and other viruses called
co-infections when you're infected with Lyme disease. But it is the gram-negative bacteria that would
produce the greatest hurt reaction. Why? Because the gram-negative bacteria in their cell membrane,
a chemical called a lipopolysaccharide. Lipopolysaccharides are extremely toxic
to us humans, to really anything. And when they're liberated by you killing a gram-negative bacteria,
it liberates it into the bloodstream, damages your lipopolysaccharides, damage your blood-brain
barrier, lipopolysaccharides are extremely toxic in our blood and we can get sick. That's really what
a hurt-side reaction is. If you're killing it in Miba, if you're running the parasite program,
the parasite program on the right, this person has a true right, the parasite program on the true
right, is not running any gram-negative bacteria programs, it's only running parasites. So a parasite,
there's a single cell organisms that are parasites, but they're not gram-negative bacteria,
so they're not liberating the Lyme polysaccharides. That's where you're going to get the most extreme
hurt-side reactions. Now that being said, most people, let's say I got a hurt-side reaction,
our misdefining that I'm getting too long and my answer to the question, but I do want to address
this. Many people, let's say I get hurt-side reactions really bad. It's really done a hurt-side
reaction. You're getting an autoimmune reaction. Just say a large percentage of people that
think they're getting hurt-side reactions have been told that it's a hurt-side reaction by a practitioner.
Many times it's an autoimmune reaction. They have antibodies to self-tissue and somehow they're
stimulating damage to that self-tissue. Many times when they have a hurt-side reactions,
antibodies to neuronal tissue. And if you get a lot of hurt-side reactions, one thing that is
wise to do is to run a Cyrex 5 and especially a Cyrex Array 7x 7x test to see if you have antibodies
to neuronal tissue. Because many times the thing that we think is a hurt-side reaction because we
feel that way is actually inflammation or damage to neuronal tissue causing spiraling inflammation
in the brain. And that could become very serious. So it's something to address. So looking at
Cyrex Array 7x will tell us definitively if that is the case. Now some that may need before you end
up with neuronal antibodies, you'll get microglial, priming. And that could give you the exact same
symptoms too. I do have a video about this. I've shared this multiple times but if you go to our website
and you look up a neurological inflammation, I think that's what it is. Neurological
inflammation. And you'll see a host that says neurological inflammation and microglial priming
have a 30-minute video that explains that in detail. And it goes into detail what
bright microglial cells are and explains that. Getting a Cyrex Array 7x test would help with that. That
is the end point of that. So when you get inflammation of the brain, have a history of Lyme disease,
you get microglial priming, it can lead to neurological antibodies being created. And that's a very
serious condition that you want to get ahead of and stay on top of and work towards correcting. It's
not, you can't correct it completely but you can manage it. So we have to get a little bit more
detail for this.